[Music]
welcome voice activation required Oh
on November third access denied god of
thunder tonight
Prince of Asgard tonight strongest
Avenger let me try
banner welcome strongest Avenger Oh what
for
Ragnarok for the bg-30 in theatres
November 3rd yet tickets now
hey hey we know each other
he's a friend from work everybody
thought you were dead
there's so much has happened since I
last saw you lost my hammer like
yesterday so that's still pretty fresh
no key Loki's alive you believe it he's
I he's up there I sense a great change
in your future
destiny has dire plans for you my friend
I have dire plans for destiny
although the goddess of death has
invaded us Gaza I thought you'd be glad
to see me
as this dead
it'll be reborn my image
neither stopper here to prevent Ragnarok
the end of everything
so putting together teams
dates
[Music]
surprise this will be such fun
I am
he's a fighter
[Music]
I'm not a cream
[Applause]
I'm the goddess of death
[Music]
what were you the god of again
[Music]
you
you